[Music]
this year is giving us a truckload of
ps4 console exclusive games with so many
to keep track of we've compiled them all
here for your convenience be sure to
subscribe and we'll keep you up to date
on everything coming to ps4 2064 read
only memories is an expanded version of
the 2015 cyberpunk adventure game of the
same name unlike the original release
the new version includes full voice
acting new puzzles and new writing
gravity rush to once again puts you in
control of cat as she goes on a gravity
defying adventure to defeat the evil
forces terrorizing the ariel city of hex
ville Kingdom Hearts HD 2.5 is a
collection that includes a
high-definition remaster of Kingdom
Hearts 3d dream Drop Distance as well as
two new pieces of story content that
expand upon the events of previous games
tales of bizarre 'ya is an action RPG
that tells the story of the ill-tempered
velvet as she journeys across the sacred
kingdom of mid gand
with a group of pirates yakaza zero is a
prequel to the well-regarded Yakuza
series set in 1988 you play as both
mainstay protagonists Kazuma Kiryu and
goro majima during the formative years
working to climb the ranks of Japan's
criminal underworld double dragon for
continues the legacy of the classic
beat-em-up series bringing back the
old-school visual style from its
earliest entries Digimon world next
order is the first Digimon world game to
reach the West in over ten years
it follows the adventures of a high
school student that gets sucked into the
digital world only to discover that it's
under siege by an army of machine
Germans wipe out Omega collection is a
remastered 4k collection of Wipeout HD
and wipeout 2048 which released on ps3
and PS Vita respectively Divide is an
open-ended sci-fi dungeon crawler that
tells the story of David a widowed
father in search of his kidnapped
daughter neo is his Dark Souls like
dungeon crawler set in a Sengoku era
Japan that's overrun by a demon
infestation it's developed by team ninja
the studio behind the brutally difficult
Ninja Gaiden series horizon zero dawn is
an upcoming open-world action RPG that
puts you in control of a hunter named
alloy as she journeys across a
post-apocalyptic world dominated by
mechanical creatures near automata is
the
Seagal to a cult favorite action RPG
released in 2010 it takes place sometime
after the events of the first game and
puts you in the role of a powerful
Android soldier tasked with driving off
an invasion of machine-like beings
Kingdom Hearts HD 1.5 plus 2.5 remix is
a ps4 re-release of the ps3
high-definition remaster ease of several
Kingdom Hearts games M will be the show
17 once again provides fans with a
realistic baseball experience while
adding a variety of new features such as
the ability to import career saves from
last year and an in-depth RPG mode that
allows you to influence the season in
myriad ways both on the field and off
danganronpa one to reload is a
collection of the first two games in the
cult favourite dangan ronpa adventure
game series the long-running Shin Megami
Tensei persona series is back with its
fifth entry it follows The Adventures of
a group of high school students who
secretly moonlight as supernatural cat
burglars the silver case is an HD
remaster of developer suda51 s first
game with studio grasshopper
manufacturer set in a city called the 24
wards it tells the story of a bizarre
series of murders and the detectives
investigating the case Dragon Quest
Heroes 2 is the latest in the mashup
series between dynasty Warriors and
Dragon Quest
it expands upon its predecessor by
providing online multiplayer with up to
four people as well as the ability to
transform into and battle as monsters
birthdays the beginning is the newest
game by legendary Japanese developer
Yasuhiro wada the creator of the Harvest
Moon series it's a colorful God game
that focuses on simple
easy-to-understand mechanics Ace Combat
7 is the first true addition to the
long-running flight simulator series in
nearly a decade it fully supports
PlayStation VR which means your dream of
being an ace fighter pilot is this much
closer to becoming a reality
boundless is a sandbox MMORPG where you
and others explore a procedurally
generated world its major highlight is
its portal mechanic which lets you place
doors that can take you to other worlds
Hatsune Miku Project Diva future tone is
a ps4 port of the rhythm game Hatsune
Miku Project Diva arcade crash bandicoot
and sane trilogy is a collection of
high-definition remasters of the
first three crash bandicoot games dangan
ronpa
v3 killing harmony continues the bloody
saga of previous games pitting another
group of students against one another in
a battle royale asked conflict of
violence and logic deaths gambit is an
atmospheric of Dark Souls like dungeon
crawler that's displayed from a 2d
side-scroller perspective
Final Fantasy 12 the zodiac age is the
high-definition remaster of the
critically acclaimed 12th entry in the
Final Fantasy series rather than build
upon the version that launched in the
u.s. in 2006 the game is a remaster of
the expanded international zodiac job
system Edition which was only released
in Japan Gran Turismo sport is the
latest entry the long-running racing
simulator series it focuses on providing
players with real-life awards for
competing in and winning FIA sponsored
racing competitions hell-blade sin us
sacrifice is the latest action game by
Ninja Theory the studio behind Heavenly
Sword enslaved Odyssey of the West and
DMC Devil May Cry the game's story is
based around Celtic mythology and tells
the story of sin Ewan a warrior
embarking on a journey through a hellish
underworld house marks latest offering
next machina death machine is a
twin-stick shooter that channel's the
energy of genre classics like Robotron
2084 and Smash TV nidhogg to brings back
its predecessors signature
back-and-forth competitive swordplay
while adding in a wealth of new
abilities and weapons as well as an
expressive new visual style ninokuni 2
revenant kingdom is the long-awaited
sequel to 2010's ninokuni wrath of the
white witch rather than focus on the
continued adventures of the protagonist
from the first game it introduces a
completely new cast of characters who
must fight against an emerging threat in
the kingdom of dingdong del pyre is the
latest game by supergiant games the
studio behind the critically acclaimed
Bastion and transistor
it's an action RPG that tasks you with
leading a band of X Isles to freedom
from a dangerous and mystical land
Parappa the rapper remastered is an HD
re-release of the fan-favorite 1997 ps1
rhythm game the long-awaited third entry
in the cult classic Shenmue series
continues ro hazuki's desperate search
for his father's killer laundy uncharted
the law
legacy is a standalone chapter in the
Uncharted series where you play as fan
favorite character
Chloe Fraser as she embarks on an
adventure in search of a mystical
treasure known as the Tusk of Ganesha
what remains of Edith Finch is an
adventure game that tells the story of
Edith the last surviving member of the
Finch family who's on a personal journey
to discover the truth behind her
mysterious heritage yakaza kiwami is a
remake of the first entry of the Yakuza
series it improves the resolution
textures and loading times of the
original as well as clear up some of
that game's more confusing plot lines
and inconsistencies and that's all the
ps4 console exclusives confirmed for
2017 but there's still time for more to
be confirmed this year so let us know in
the comments below what other games you
think will come out for more on all
things ps4 stick to GameSpot
[Music]